c'est un débat qui divise mais qui a au
moins l'avantagé d'être opposé hier soir
dans balances ton post les participants
à l'émission ont échangé sur une
question fondamentale
faut-il continuer à protéger les plus
fragiles en arrêtant toute vie sociale
doit-on reprendre notre vie d'avant
quitte à risquer celle des plus âgés il
a posé la vraie question de la forêt
chez désolé excusez-moi d'un débat que
l'écrivain yann moix a tranché pour lui
il faut arrêter d'avoir peur et de ne
pas prendre de risques nous sommes dans
un délire collectif qui auront
maintenant depuis un an on a une maladie
qui est relativement dangereuse mais pas
plus qu'une autre sur ne renonce pas
mourir à 80,85 on a raté sa vie même une
position qui a fait grincer des dents en
plateau sur les réseaux sociaux en temps
yann moix persiste et signe
la santé mentale de tous est aussi
importante que la vie des plus âgés
pourquoi est-ce que vous donner la
priorité à la mort physique sur la mort
sociale une intervention qu'il a conclu
par ces mots
alors doit-on tout rouvrir ou risque de
sacrifier les personnes âgées ce soir
yann moix revient sur la polémique qu'il
a déclenchée hier soir et il fera face
au docteur jean paul hamon oui
yann moix était avec moi hier soir aux
balances ton post a cartonné d'ailleurs
merci de revenir aujourd'hui yann voilà
que je suis très content de te voir
comme d'habitude et c'est vrai que tu
étais excellent fier et très content de
voir aussi le docteur jean paul hamon
qui veut la peau des généralistes et il
vient de le dédicacer pompe a pas que ça
me fait extrêmement plaisir
merci docteur jean paul hamon président
d'honneur de la fédération des médecins
de france
alors c'est vrai que cette phrase tout
le monde en a parlé toute la journée sur
les réseaux sociaux
ça a été un déferlement et la question
est simple doit-on tout couvrir au
risque de sacrifier des personnes âgées
j'aimerais d'abord me tourner vers ian e
qui va peut-être nous reparler de son
propos d'hier soit n'ai pas changé
d'avis entre hier soir non seulement
j'ai pas changé d'avis mais on est
absolument ni l'intention ni l'année
j'ai pas l'intérêt de le faire et je
crois que alors contraire il faut le
marteler cet avis est important alors
est-ce que vous pouvez re préciser et
redire ce que vous avez dit hier soir
salle ray simple d'abord je n'aime pas
le mot de sacrifices parce qu'il ne
s'agit pas de sacrifier qui compte
d'accord qu'on que l'idée que je formule
hier que est la suivante dans une
société où les jeunes sont privés
d'avenir où l'avenir est remplacé par l'
angoisse ou la paralysie et total on a
fait le choix ou on ne fait accroire
qu'il fallait avoir le choix entre la
chose suivante soigner
les gens dans l'urgence total qui sont
des personnes concernées par le virus
des gens qui ont des maladies ou des
gens âgés la moyenne d'âge du virus de
la mortalité du virus est de 83 ans on
le sait ou bien de sacrifier une partie
de la france
et moi je dis une chose très simple
jeudi que les médecins notamment et
beaucoup d'intermédiaires fonds de l'avs
entrer le ventriloquie et parle à la
place de deux catégories de personnes
non seulement il plas il parle à la
place des jeunes qui n'ont pas d'avenir
mais surtout et c'est tout j'ai appris
aujourd'hui en ayant énormément de
témoignages de la part de personnes
âgées
il parle également à la place des vieux
qui seraient ravis que les restaurants
et les boîtes de nuit les bibliothèques
ouvre parce que ils pensent que l'avenir
de leurs petits enfants est plus
important que leur avenir et je
rajouterais cyril et ça beaucoup de
médecins ne le savent pas qui est une
grande différence entre vivre et exister
la vis une vie biologique tout le monde
en a une les animaux les êtres humains
ont une jolie mais l'existence c'est
quoi une racine latine existerait ça
veut dire se projeter dans ceux projetés
sortir de soi même pour aller vers
l'avenir
seuls les jeunes ont la capacité de se
projeter dans l'avenir et je suis désolé
cyril on a on a sacrifié des générations
à la guerre en 14 ou des jeunes de 20
ans sont allés défendre le pays on nous
rebat les oreilles avec des mots comme
couvre-feu ou mobilisation générale donc
c'est qu'à une guerre et bien voilà la
première guerre ou peut-être les
combattants seront les vieillards et non
plus les jeunes générations
c'est triste à dire mais il serait
hypocrite de ne pas croire que les
médecins ne font pas de choix de temps
en temps entre deux personnes
c'est à dire une personne de 85 ans une
personne de 20 ans si on pense que
toutes les vies humaines se valent alors
il faut aussi accepter que vingt mille
migrants se noient en méditerranée
depuis 2000 2014 on peut nommer
ça peut aller très loin chaque année je
pense et je après je me tais syrie on va
laisser dire que le véritable potentiel
d'un pays c'est l'avenir et que s'il n'y
a pas d'avenir
nous sommes dans une perpétuelle
angoisses et je rajouterais que rien
n'est plus précieux au monde qu'une
journée humaine sur la planète terre une
journée humaine cyril une journée où on
se lève le matin on se couche le soir on
a fait des choses intéressantes de sa
vie à l'intérieur avec une densité
absurde quand on a même 95 ans mais
magnifique quand on a 25 ans quand on
peut remplir ses journées
d'avenir du projet de proposition
d'amour de rencontre et croire aussi que
le cinéma le théâtre ce n'est fait que
pour décorer le réel c'est faux mais
sans public les artistes n'ont pas
d'inspiration sans inspiration les
articles les artistes se suicident
malraux a dit une chose que j'adore sans
l'art tous les hommes se suiciderait
l'art n'est pas fait pour faire beau
l'art est fait pour adoucir la vie est
proposé aux gens qui n'ont pas de vie
intéressante une existence précisément
sans le cinéma sans le théâtre sans les
concerts nous ne sommes que des
vermisseau et je crois que sans les
jeunes sans avenir et sans projet la
france devient un pays sclérosé et je
crois que la plupart des personnes âgées
comprennent mieux que les médecins qui
font de la ventriloque et leur plein ce
que je chante on dira alors on va avoir
la vie de jean paul à londres dans un
instant je voudrais juste savoir
isabelle qui attend que vous aimez
n'oubliez pas mais bien redit là ce que
vous avez mal d'hier soir cameron
sourire hier soir alors en radicalisant
en radicalisant le propos parce que la
france et d'avenir c'est aussi la
mémoire c'est aussi la wii mais
effectivement qu'isabelle vous étiez la
journée s'est très clairement les jeunes
les 22 ans et les 80 90 ans si on n'est
pas prêt à mourir à 84 ans pour deux en
plus c'est qu'on a raté sa vie oui je
pense que vous en savez est infinie
qu'est ce que vous en savez d'abord et
ensuite pardonnez moi mais il ya
énormément de jeunes de 22 ans qui n'ont
qu'une envie c'est que leurs
grands-parents de 84 ans reste le plus
longtemps en vie madame jour contre là
dessus je crois qu'il est beaucoup plus
naturel qu'une personne de 85 ans veille
de l'avenir pour son arrière petit fils
ou petit fils que l' inverse
mais ça n'empêche et je crois je crois
madame grès sincèrement que lorsqu'on a
85 ans la vie est derrière soi et quand
on a 25 ans on a envie d'aller
travailler c'est un droit d'aller
travailler là n'a le droit de sortir de
vivre d'exister de voir des amis et
surtout de ceux proposés à soi même
un projet que la société en ce moment
est en train d'asphyxier et je crois en
rien un clic vous fait
tous une grave erreur la plupart d'entre
vous et les médecins c'est de croire que
la santé c'est le contraire de la
maladie la santé c'est un bien-être
c'est l'absence d'angoissé la santé
c'est de pouvoir sortir de chez soi en
se sentant bien ça veut dire
psychologiquement bien moralement bien
amoureusement bien affectivement bien
socialement bien et culturellement bien
et la santé ne consiste pas petit à
n'avoir pas de maladie et petits de ne
pas avoir le corps d'un virus car il ya
aussi cent mille personnes qui meurent
du cancer tous les ans et en ce moment
des gens se laissent mourir chez eux pas
simplement de chagrin pas simplement de
tristesse pas simplement d'angoissé
parce que des suicides chez des
adolescents chez les enfants mais tout
simplement parce qu'ils nous ont pas
soigné parce que les pauvres n'ont pas
la chance d'avoir le peuvent alors
j'aimerais avoir l'avis du docteur
jean-paul à bellocq
alors oui le ventriloque exactement moi
je vais pas vous faire de citations
latines mais je vais vous dire que mon
plus vieil utilisateurs de viagra il
avait 81 18 ans et quand je disais fais
gaffe il me disait tu sais qu est ce que
tu me qui m'arrive nouveau jean paul
geai un type de 84 ans qui est allé
faire le tour de chine en trois semaines
1 il a fait ça à l'américaine c'est à
dire qu'ils prenaient l'avion le matin
le train chéri quand il est venu voir en
consultation ratant jeu peut en placer
une
ils sont il est venu boire en
consultation 84 ans il m'a dit je sais
pas ce que j'échoue sens un peu fatigué
les mecs j'ai une balade gnet 103 ans
103 ans qui s'est retrouvé enfermé dans
sa piaule est là elle a mis à les
accrocher un droit au radiateur elle est
descendue par la fenêtre du premier
étage et montgueux l'air quand elle
avait s'entend quand tu allais quand la
belle tête qui tournait quand et ramassé
sérique au vert arrêtez arrêtez ça
allait dire dire que les vieux n'ont pas
d'avenir moi j'avais une mémé qui
venaient me voir avec une 504 qui avait
pas la direction assistée ils doivent se
garer il se gare de travers et qui me
disait vous savez docteur à 81 84 ap by
the doctor je suis inquiète pour mon
avenir
donc les dires dire que les vieux n'ont
pas d'avenir et ses seins faut arrêter
s'arrêter à penser que les jeunes on
sait que les jeunes souffrent en ce
moment mais je peux vous dire que si on
laisse courir le virus si on laisse
courir en rire user vos salades là on va
choisir on va choisir à qui nous varient
mais excusez moi je vous hais le côté
vous avez bien préparer votre finances
laissez moi on doit répondre c'est jean
paul dessy si on laisse courir si on
laisse courir le virus c'est simple
quand on a quand on a décidé de confiner
paris la premier confinement
qu'entendait dessinée il restait plus
que deux ligues de réanimation pour
l'île de france 2 il fallait absolument
confiner le pays
1 et là on sait très bien on sait très
bien que les jeunes souffrent mais je
voudrais juste un exemple
avant-hier les jeux de vision des jeunes
de 18 ans les jeunes de 18 ans qui ont
fait ces acteurs qui ont fêté
l'anniversaire de deux mondes
il était tout une case confère
déversèrent de leurs copains de 18 ans
y'a quand même à neuf quand le candidat
maintenant et est là et il y en a deux
et y en a deux teasers sont vraiment pas
bien quand vous aviez 20 ans vous auriez
m enfermer toute la journée
non mais attendez docteur en ce moment
vous exercez votre profession et il ya
des gens de 35 ans qui vont mourir parce
qu'ils ne peuvent plus exercer leur
profession parce que des gens de 85 ans
il y en a 45 ans qui en réalité 2 de v
de 4,1 pour cent sont en train de mourir
pour une maladie qui n'est pas plus
dangereuse qu'une autre
ça fait un an et demi que des gens comme
vous des cloques tentera de nous
enfermer au prétexte que la maladie est
la chose la plus grave du monde et
qu'ils elles cette maladie s'appelle
locaux vides et pour des raisons
sanitaires
vous êtes en train d'oublier toutes les
autres maladies mentales cérébrale
psychologique qui font des ravages jeu
il y en a quatre
oui il y en a qu il y en a un qui a pas
oublié les maladies mentales je pense
parce que c'est macron quand il a décidé
de pas confiné parce que là on sait on
sait qu'actuellement je vous fais le
virus le virus il est on est sur un
plafond ces cinq années ou qui est raide
un plateau qui est très très élevé mais
qui est mon corps accepte habré mais il
a pensé que comme dans les eaux usées le
virus baisse et qu'il va y avoir les
vacances scolaires qui vont couper une
partie de l'épidémie il va y avoir à
peut-être un petit trou de souris ça
dans lequel on va passer parce que ce
qu'il a entendu
c'est que effectivement en france il ya
énormément de maladie mentale
il ya énormément de gens déprimés et
figurez-vous que j'envoie quelques-uns
dans mon cabinet du docteur chez un peu
bêtement alors que je vous apprécie
vraiment vous le savez j'ai du respect
pour don classé suivent et non par peu
par rapport aux si c'est pas du tout
personnage j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
lui je vais quand même vous dire une
chose
l'agacement
beaucoup de jeunes c'est que le discours
que vous tenez ce soir il est ce qu'il
est c'est à dire que c'est un discours
médical mais ce n'est pas de votre faute
j'aimerais vous mettre en garde contre
une chose c'est le fait que nous sommes
saturés par ce discours de spécialistes
dont qui nous donne l'impression qu'on
fait du ski nautique derrière le virus
que c'est le virus qui nous dicte nos
lois alors moi je voudrais bien entendre
ce que vous dites mais six adore ça dure
encore six ans
au bout d'un moment on va être obligé de
dire stop c'est à dire que les nommer
monsieur de france ça va pas durer six
ans déjà et en disant je vous explique
sa fille non je sais ça va pas de là
pourquoi ça va durer six ans que
pourquoi pourquoi il faut arrêter ce
virus parce que déjà il ya des variants
est le variant brésilien on n'est pas
certain que les vaccins actuels sont
efficaces contre la reggina et
heureusement
heureusement que techniquement
maintenant grâce aux arn messager on
peut va pouvoir adapter le virus dont on
va pouvoir adapter les vaccins avec une
affiche un silo est seulement là ce que
ce que moi honnêtement je pensais qu'on
serait peinard cet été mais un c'est bon
si le virus à se calmer seulement
l'apparition des variants fait qu'on
réfléchisse autrement je pense
sincèrement qu'on pourra vraiment
respirer on va respirer cet été parce
qu'on va vivre dehors etc
on va commencer à respirer en avril mais
ça sera plus stable
peut-être que les restaurants pour
ouvrir en terrasse parce que en soit ma
grande écoute que c'est peut-être tuer
les gens mais parce que mes parents n'en
sais rien c'est pas de regarder ce qui
s'est passé que le variant angles est là
on est en train de s'emmerder en train
de faire des séquençages machin mais là
les gamins ils n'étaient pas toucher à
la première vague
l'un maintenant il ya des classes
entières qui sont touchés et alors ok
alors
il ya un truc que vous publiez vraiment
ça patine il y a dans cette dans ce
début de siècle quelque chose qui me
consterne
c'est à dire que et ça c'est pas de
votre faute si une vision sans doute
scientiste du monde qui revient comme on
en a eu dix neuvième siècle qui est que
la mort est devenu quelque chose de
parfaitement scandaleux la mort et
devient presque illégitime devient
presque illégale et c'est devenu le
grand tabou la société il ya eu une
époque on avait peur de nos morts
maintenant on a peur de nos vivants
c'est à dire que les vivants sont
tétanisés à l'idée de ne pas rentrer
chez eux le soir en sortant le matin
parce qu'ils vont peut-être se fait
renverser alors on fera un procès à
l'état parce que les routes sont pas
entretenues de chopé un virus et on fera
un procès à l'état parce que l'état n'a
pas pu anticiper quelque chose qui était
quasiment pas anticipable et donc si
vous voulez il ya un mélange de
procédures iations perpétuel et de
d'assainissement de la réalité on veut
absolument tout lycée pour que plus rien
ne soit dangereux vivre est extrêmement
dangereux respirer on est dangereux
parce qu'on peut respirer départ la
bulle finale avait jeté une maladie mais
elle tout le monde en convient c'est sur
une journée où des gens des piétons
marchent vous me citez les quatre
entorses que vous connaissez ça me fait
une belle jambe
alors ça c'est juste vous vous êtes prêt
à sacrifier donc les mêmes pas le mot de
sacrifier par ailleurs dit une chose
très juste alors vous dire des pouvoirs
ce que la meilleure je n'explique pas ce
qu'il faut pas non plus dire n'importe
quoi le docteur dit une chose très juste
c'est que ce n'est pas parce que quand
on a 88 ans qu'on a tout dit cm je suis
pas parce qu'on a 92 ans qu'on n'arrive
rien à faire ni à dire on est d'accord
jeudi simple ça serait abject de dire ça
je dis simplement que dans des
situations de guerre ou de crise il est
hypocrite de nous faire croire toute la
journée coup nom du sauvetage d une
tranche d'âge très âgées on doit à
asphyxier le reste de la société parce
que dans ce cas là cyril la cola le
pansement serait beaucoup plus grave que
la maladie elle-même les baies qui
serait plus grave que le handicap alors
et l'asphyxient mental et social qui se
passe mais on a vu des gens qui sont
fiers borgeaud zafy était borderline
joseph sonné mois ci voit les orateurs
ce que je vois est ce que je sais c'est
qu'il ya d'autres maladies sociétales
sociales mentale et culturelles qui sont
en train de faire des ravages et celles
là sont niés voire moqué mais encore là
c'est enfin et surtout surtout ce qui
est ce qui est gravissime c'est que à
cause de cette maladie
on est obligé de reculer des
hospitalisations de receler des
interventions assure ya des gens qui ne
se soignent plus on voit bien que là on
est on est vraiment dans un système si
vous laissiez pour ça que vous avez tort
de dire qu'il faut laisser circuler ce
virus parce que le système de santé ne
tiendra pas et on sait bien mais tout
tout ce que vous avez dit sur les
adolescents sur les dépressions etc
je peux vous dire ça moi je les vois il
faut quotidiennement quotidiennement
fosseux région sont tous rêvent rire et
chansons comprennent les gens et en
prêts à prendre des risques
comme j'aimerais bien les restos moi
vous savez ce qui me ferait plaisir pour
écrire salle sur des places de paris
qu'on installe des chapiteaux que sont
ouverts sur les côtés et que les jeux
colonne de nouveau réveillée en puisse
mettre des délais par le seul choquant
pour que les gens puissent vivre
ensemble ses vingt deux mètres d'écart
parce que quand vous êtes abonné sabine
est à moins de deux mètres
vous vous contaminer malheureusement et
c'est pour ça que c'est triste pour les
restaurants je sais ce qu'il nous reste
deux minutes on est juste je voudrais
juste un oui à non juste guillaume
genton oui non je suis complètement
d'accord et cannois que c'est peut-être
politiquement incorrect de dire ça mais
quand on a 80 85 ans on a plus de vécu
que quand on a 25 ans et 5 à 20 ans
c'est très bien aujourd'hui non mais à
20 ans il reste encore 60 balais mais la
leur pour toi temps mais ça n'a pas duré
des plans devaient d'abord mais aussi
dans un long temps en nombre soit
peinard vanessa que vous aviez 20 ans
l'an rentrer dans la deuxième année de
colis des deux ans dans une courte en
journée l'auteur pense que ça va ou
personnes âgées juste bien regarder
jouer que derrida les outils les le le
coup honnête si demain on ouvre tout moi
et moi savoir ce que vous fassiez vous
prêt à faire des modélisations
aujourd'hui on ouvre tous les théâtres
et restaurants et que ça nous coûte en
termes de vie combien de ces grades de
dire ça quand même
il pose la bonne économie mondiale
depuis 100 ans a fait des pour et des
contres quelques sanogo des contrôles
menés bon bout ils ont très bonne
question j'aimerais ça ils ont fait ça
en belgique ils ont fait ça hollande je
peux vous dire qu'ils ont un mec non vie
ou cool ils ont vite remis les freins
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une contagion
énorme
il ya une contagion énorme mais quand
vous avez un nombre de personnes
touchées énorme et bien vous avez
beaucoup de personnes ans de
spécialisation et les capacités de
réanimation labs est obligé de faire des
choix c'est à dire que là vous dites
attention la une à 50 balais je vais
il ya soixante balais mais je leur aie n
aimerais pas là 60 balais pour hannibal
pas un mec voudriez que du wi latine
vous posais une question si c'est
pourquoi le fait de réouvrir est
directement synonyme de décès pour les
personnes âgées dans le sens où par
exemple mon père hollandais donc
justement hollande mon père mon grand
père pardon qui lui a 80 ans et il a un
cancer il a eu le coc vide
il s'en est très bien sortie il n'a pas
été hospitalisé tout va très bien
mon père je suis désolé je sais que
votre père est l'habitant ou l'ordi l'a
jamais il a il a une copine il a un
cancer il se porte super bien
aujourd'hui tout va trop loin et la
paille tôt ce samedi matin
je suis content pour votre grand père
wilko jambe droite d'ailleurs qui
s'appelle comment oh pas non au pas il
s'est vraiment verte d'accord berthod et
voilà je suis content mon lit je pense
qu'il a eu de la chance
non mais oui on a eu du bon j'ai deux
petits enfants enfin le du gaullisme le
petit fils avec sa femme ils ils ont ils
accueillent leur grand-mère a depuis
longtemps tous les deux commis tous les
deux ans le choper la grand mère l'a
fait leur regard est une qui était là la
jeune a été hospitalisé la lame et mecha
92 en nickel chrome à laval a été
positif l arrière fait qu'elle roulait
tout c'est ça qui est incroyable c'est
que la houlette rejouer que nous dit oui
d'où il s'est très vite
allez-y bon bah on continue d'associer
la liberté des ans avec la mort des
autres
en fait un clivage maladie les personnes
qui mort du co vide qui sont vraiment
sous frank et moi la quille en meurent
on sait qu'ils cessent les personnes
très âgées les personnes fragiles
pourquoi aujourd'hui on fait passer
enfin nos vies en fait on laisse nos
vies totalement à l'abandon pour les
personnes qui puisait ont connu l'âge
d'or
ces personnes là elles ont tous dit pas
qu'il faut les sacrifier sa version
puisque aux écritures les années 60 il y
a eu tout mais on va encore là on a 30
secondes à vaches et les cochons avec
sept mois que moi je suis totalement
d'accord et je leur dis souvent c'est
une espèce si jeune et c'est vraiment
s'il vous plaît 54% de oui c'est assez
incroyable